so today we are pleased to welcome
shalonda young and cecilia rouse to the
briefing room to address your questions
on the 2023 budget
we have just a few announcements before
they go into the president's budget as
we disclose to all of you
this morning the president tested
negative as a part of his regular
testing cadence he was last tested
friday as a part of his regular testing
rhythm and additional testing
requirements uh for travel to and from
europe moving forward he will proceed on
his regular testing schedule and we will
continue to update all of you out of an
abundance of transparency
and of course we wish kareem and jen's
speedy recoveries they are currently
both following cdc guidance and will be
back following a negative test
jyn shared this morning that she's
feeling stir crazy and will be back soon
first on judge jackson
judge jackson continued to build support
last week after she spent over 20 hours
in marathon confirmation hearings
demonstrating her credentials intellect
character grace and the value of her
deep experience
she reminded the country of why the
president chose her and why she has been
endorsed by conservative judges the
fraternal order of police the
international association of chiefs of
police
dozens of police chiefs and sheriffs who
lead many of the busiest departments in
the united states
and 83 former state attorneys general
from both parties
polls keep showing that she has strong
backing among the american people
with some indicating that she has the
most support of any supreme court
nominee since john roberts who she ties
with and whom she shares and with whom
she shares a similar philosophy about
judges serving as referees who decide
cases based on the law and the facts
she has now met with more than a
majority of the senate and is continuing
her engagement with senators today and
throughout the week
judge jackson responded to republicans
request for in-person meetings by
promising to sit down with any member
who wanted to and she is honoring that
promise
something else that speaks to the
strength of judge jackson's
qualifications
which a series of republicans have
affirmed make her unquestionably fit to
serve on the supreme court
and to the strength of her record is the
multitude of fact checks from the press
from retired judges and from former
prosecutors who have dismantled attacks
brought by a small group of gop senators
the truth is that every single one of
the specific senators who joined in
these bad faith attacks on her
sentencing record with respect to child
pornography
has voted for numerous trump-nominated
judges who sentenced defendants for the
same crimes in the same fashion below
guidelines widely considered to be out
of date across the judiciary and below
what prosecutors sought which is also a
norm
for example last week the washington
post fact checker wrote a piece
headlined these trump judges fail
holly's sentencing test for jackson
the new york times fact-checking team
also covered this writing
critics of jackson's child sex abuse
sentences backed judges with similar
records
the trump-nominated judges they surveyed
received broad support and even included
sixth circuit judge amul the par who was
on donald trump's short list for the
supreme court
this was all on top of a raft of other
fact checks already establishing that
the basis of these criticisms was
dishonest
and then in terms of the budget as you
heard the president discuss earlier
today
he has released his second budget which
builds on historic deficit reduction his
agenda is delivering by means of the
fastest economic growth in almost 40
years on top of record-breaking job
creation and unemployment reduction in
2021.
the president's budget will help bring
more jobs back to america make us safer
at home by increasing funding for police
and more secure in the world by
investing in our national security and
alliances and it will pay for these
crucial policies by asking the ultra
wealthy the top 100th of one percent of
americans in terms of income
billionaires and 100 millionaires to pay
an income tax that's aligned with what
most people in the workforce pay
we encourage republicans in congress to
support that approach
rather than their proposal to raise
taxes on half of working families and
taking health care coverage away from
millions while gutting protections for
americans with pre-existing conditions
in order to hand out even more tax
giveaways to the wealthiest
uh shalonda young is joining us for the
first time in the briefing room
she is the director of the office of
management budget and budget having been
confirmed by the senate with bipartisan
support earlier this month as director
she serves as a senior advisor to
president biden and plays a critical
role in implementing the president's
vision across the executive branch
previously shalonda was the acting
director of omb for the last year and
the clerk and staff director for the
house appropriations committee where she
oversaw the 1.3 trillion annual
appropriations bills
uh we're also joined by cecilia rouse
who has been here uh numerous times who
is the chair of the council of economic
advisors and a member of the president's
family's cabinet
as a quick introduction she is a world
respected labor economist who recently
served as dean of the princeton school
of public and international affairs she
previously served as a member of the
council of economic advisors in the
obama biden administration and on the
national economic council in the clinton
administration
and with that i'm going to turn it over
to each of them we'll give remarks and
then i'll call on folks for questions
and then once we're done we're happy to
take more questions from you all
throughout the day in the press office
[Music]
all right be nice to the newbie
[Laughter]
for omb director this is like uh prom
day so i'm
very happy to be here with you today uh
you've heard the president say this you
heard him say it
this morning budgets are about values in
his 2023 budget puts our values to work
in three key ways first is fiscally
responsible the budget shows that we're
on try to reduce the deficit by more
than 1.3 trillion dollars this is the
largest year-over-year decline uh in
history and less than half of the
deficit the president inherited
and that's no accident it's a result of
the president's strategy to combat the
pandemic and grow our economy a strategy
that has built on smart investments and
helped jump start our recovery
and that strategy has paid off
in 2021 we created more than 6.5 million
jobs the most our country has ever
recorded in a single year our economy
grew 5.7 percent the most in 40 years
and the unemployment rate has fallen to
3.8 percent the fastest decline in
recorded history
because of that progress we're able to
responsibly draw down emergency spending
measures and increase revenues the
budget outlines the president's vision
to expand on this progress
its investments are more than fully paid
for through tax reforms ensure
corporations and the wealthiest
americans pay their fair share it
achieves significant deficit reduction
over the next decade
and it ensures no one earning less than
four hundred thousand dollars pays a
penny more in new taxes
second the budget invests in security
both here and abroad here at home it
includes investments to keep our
communities safe put more cops on the
beat for community policing fight gun
crime and advance criminal justice
reform the budget also strengthens our
military and leverages our renewed
strength at home to meet pressing global
challenges
making one of the largest investments in
our national security in u.s history
third the budget will help us build a
better america by investing in education
making more here at home combating the
opioid epidemic driving medical
breakthroughs including
in cancer and taking on the mental
health crisis the budget also makes
clear that the president is committed to
working with congress to pass
legislation that reduces the deficit
cuts costs for families and expands the
productive capacity of our economy
these are all things we can make
progress on together and we're looking
forward to working with congress to
advance these priorities for the
american people thank you
[Music]
good afternoon
this budget builds on the solid economic
gains of the first year of this
administration
the recovery over the last year has been
extraordinary quicker than independent
forecasters had projected
over 2021 real output grew by 5.6
the fastest since 1984.
the unemployment rate fell at its
fastest pace since modern data began in
1948.
the labor force participation rate of
americans ages 25 to 54 grew by the most
since 1979.
this robust recovery has put us in a
strong position today
the us economy is more than three
percent larger in inflation-adjusted
terms than it was just before the
pandemic the fastest recovery in the g7
healthy household balance sheets and a
strong labor market make us more
resilient to external shocks the strong
recovery has also put us in a better
fiscal position as faster growth helps
lower the deficit
the budget builds on this solid economic
growth it is a continuation of president
biden's commitment to address
long-standing issues in the economy and
make investments that will ensure robust
sustainable and equitable growth
first the budget is fiscally responsible
thanks to the american rescue plan
revenues are up and pandemic relief can
slow down
the result is deficit reduction which
will help ease long-term inflationary
pressures and make our fiscal trajectory
more sustainable
second the buzzer the budget bolsters
domestic and foreign security
increased security here and abroad not
only protects lives but it also reduces
uncertainty which allows economic
activity the room it needs to
re-normalize and grow
third the economy makes important
investments in the american people a
healthy cared-for workforce is a
productive workforce and it lowers cost
for families easing price pressures over
the longer term
now i'd like to close with a word about
our forecast
in many ways the forecast looks
healthier today than it did when we
locked it all the way back last november
the economy has created on average uh
600 000 jobs per much since months since
then including through the omicron wave
and the unemployment rate has fallen an
additional 0.8 percentage point
challenges have also arisen since last
november as well
the most obvious is the russian invasion
of ukraine
this may well put upward pressure on
energy and food prices
that in turn could reinforce inflation
which was already an issue prior to the
invasion due to the pandemic supply
chain constraints and a strong demand
for goods
but as i said earlier the strength of
our recovery has put us on solid ground
to weather economic shocks
independent forecasters anticipate that
inflation will come down
americans are back to work and the
economy is strong the president's 2023
budget presents a fiscally fair and
responsible approach to continue to
invest in america and meet future
challenges
josh would you like to start us
sure uh
director young josh buzz with ap
um
i want to understand the uh
reserve fund for whatever comes out of
negotiations with congress
you said on the call this morning that
talks are ongoing
um the budget
says
uh of the president's priorities they
include the expanded child tax credit
something that we previously believed
was off the table
can you give us a sense of where
negotiations are and what we could
expect in terms of how active they are
such that you felt obligated to exclude
those priorities from the total
one let me start where you end it
they're not excluded
what we didn't do is detail things so we
did not get ahead of negotiations
you probably heard that i spent a little
time on capitol hill
what we don't do is get ahead of
congressional negotiations
we certainly don't negotiate in public
the reserve fund is meant to hold
revenues enough for whatever framework
comes out of congress what we're not
doing is double counting revenue so the
revenues we're holding
in the reserve fund are different for
example we're not counting the savings
from prescription drug reform
in the deficit neutral reserve fund that
they can use that if they want we're not
counting that for our 23 uh budget so
one we're not going to negotiate in
public to we need to leave revenues for
legislation the president has
consistently called on congress
to send to his desk um and
that that is i think as as clear as i
can be sure but it's been an exhausting
month as we can all attest to and i
imagine that's true for you as well
have you had any talks or negotiations
with regard to this in the last month
with members of congress look i think a
easy way to not get anything done is to
negotiate in public we're not going to
do that
the 23 budget i think is the responsible
thing to do to hold enough revenues
so congress can use those if it wants
to send legislation to the president
that reduces the deficit and reduces
costs for the american people
sabrina
thank you so much you're placing a lot
of emphasis with this budget on deficit
reduction can you talk a little bit more
about that is it an effort to persuade
senator manchin and other centers who
have raised concerns about the deficit
or do does your administration believe
that the deficit isn't that getting too
high let me remind you this presidency
of a budget this is the second one uh
and in both budgets he has paid for his
proposals
this is a classic joe biden budget um so
just as he did last year we're putting
before ford proposals that do two things
establishes a tax system that's fair
where corporations and the wealthiest
pay their fair share but it has added
benefit of paying for
uh needs of the american people like
reducing child care
and what other what specific proposals
beyond the wealth tax would lower the
deficit by a trillion dollars over the
next decade as you say so one we're
already in the process from last year to
this year reducing the deficit by 1.3
trillion dollars
the proposals in the budget would also
bring about another
trillion dollar decrease
in addition to the billionaire income
tax proposal that we have in the budget
we also
believe that we should take the
individual rate back to 39.6 percent but
also bring uh corporate uh corporate tax
rates back up uh not even quite back up
to where they were before the trump tax
cuts steve
cecilia you mentioned that the ukraine
invasion is going to have a complicated
complicated inflation could you talk a
little bit more about that what should
americans expect i
expect higher gasoline prices
food what do you think so um
so as the president just said this is
this is an important this is an
important place for the united states
this is an important moment for
democracy um and but what we do know is
that putin's invasion of ukraine will
have impacts on both energy prices and
food prices so we he has as the
president has said we can expect that
while our sanctions are going to have
their focus and most of their impact on
the russian economy that we can expect
that we will see a bit of impact in the
united states as well so the first we're
seeing is uh some impact on gas prices
and oil prices we can also expect
through fertilizer and energy prices to
see some impact on food
that said the president is focused on
doing what he can to ensure that those
increases are contained and that they
are not the you know they're doing what
he can to ease them for the american
people so that is he's worked with our
partners to increase an additional 60
million barrels from the the strategic
petroleum reserve um and he has uh he
has other options on the table that he
will be considering
as as they come up in terms of food
prices
you know the u.s we we don't expect a
shortage here
because we are net exporters uh but we
are acutely aware of the fact that there
are regions in the world that depend
heavily on exports of wheat in
particular and other greens from the
ukraine and russia and we're working
with our partners to ensure
to minimize the impacts globally
nancy just um for dr ross just following
up on what you said how is the white
house preparing to deal with those food
shortages particularly when it comes to
wheat in places like africa the middle
east and the developing countries and
and should us farmers grow more wheat
this year instead of corn and soybeans
given given those
possible food shortages so first of all
we are a net exporter of many of those
uh food commodities and
farmers respond to price signals and so
with the price of food rising they will
be responding by
making additional plantings and trying
to take advantage of the increased price
signals so the market will work as the
market will work but the us is working
with our partners usaid is right in the
middle of it and other international
food organizations to it to get the food
and to ease the price pressures for
other uh countries around the world
follow up on that i'm sorry to follow up
on that is there um are you having um is
there any are you think i'm sorry um
have you considered altering the
sanctions to make it clear that there's
no restrictions on agricultural trade
with russia so the sanctions have always
had carve outs for humanitarian needs
the the the focus of the sanctions was
to be on putin and his close circle but
to not make to minimize to the extent
possible the impact on the russian
people so there has been a carve out for
humanitarian aid and we will absolutely
be working to ensure that they get the
the food that they need so you just
forget about that
yeah thanks andrew i wanted to follow up
on what the administration's proposed uh
in police funding uh so 3.2 billion uh
is for grants local state grants then
the other 30 billion the white house has
called it quote mandatory resources to
support law enforcement what does it
mean by mandatory um and how will that
money flow to
uh presumably local governments and
states for for police forces so you know
the budget uh two major spending
categories discretionary which will go
through the appropriations process
that is where we're asking for the 3.2
billion dollars
there are traditional accounts like the
community oriented policing account and
burn jag that the appropriations
committee already funds we're asking for
increases uh in those accounts the
mandatory side it is a new proposal
we would have to work with and are
planning to work with the authorizers
who typically move mandatory legislation
on the parameters of that funding
but what is clear and you heard the
president talk about this earlier in
addition to cops on the b
we want a community focus
we also know that it takes a
comprehensive approach
that police forces around the country
should have mental health services
psychiatrists that's why our community
violence initiative we're asking for
money not only in doj and in hhs on the
discretionary side so the plan is on the
mandatory side is a new proposal to work
with those authorizing committees to
ensure uh that it is uh both strong on
the policing side but also have these
services goals in terms of how many more
are
wraparound
police officers could be added
nationwide or any priorities you
mentioned a couple of them but in terms
of what you want to see this money uh
used on and how much leeway will uh
police forces have versus
it coming down from the federal
government on where the money can get
as you know these decisions are best
made at the local level not even the
state most often when it comes to
policing efforts so
my
what we plan on doing is working with
the judiciary committees um to ensure
that we provide flexible enough funding
but be very clear that we expect a
community uh focus and also that we have
the wraparound services necessary
including mental health services to make
sure that we bring down violence in our
communities
who have who have left their job do you
take that into
ul has said account the uh inflation
estimates for this budget were set in
november
um and if the invasion were to be taken
into account the outlook would look
pretty different so should we expect an
updated analysis from this
administration on that front to take
into account the invasion
and also just in terms of the timeline
do you all have an estimate for when
people can expect things to level out
again can we expect that during this
calendar year so uh we will be doing a
mid-session update of our budget uh
later this summer that is typically what
we do and obviously for next year's
budget will be we will use a new budget
that will not be quite as uh old at
least for next year um uh you know
outside forecasters uh who have been you
know who are studying this as well uh
expect that inflation will be higher
than they were anticipating back when we
locked our budget so then at the
beginning of the year before the
invasion but they do expect that as we
learn to maintain economic activity uh
while we are still working through this
pandemic
while we
while supply chains
continue to improve although obviously
there's there's uncertainty there with
for example lockdowns in china but we
expect them to work through that that we
expect supply chain challenges to ease
we do expect inflation to ease this year
and into next
go but just send us year other questions
you have in the press office what
happened
thanks for coming
thank you